bonjour à tous merci d'être là patate
chibli cloud moi même la havre l exposé
qu'on a eue alors je commençais avec
cette phrase de paul valéry sur le fait
que le futur n'est plus ce qu'il était
le futur n'est plus ce qu'il était dans
la gestion des infrastructures urbaines
dans la gestion des bâtiments est donc
dans la gestion des informations et des
données qui sont sous-jacentes à
l'ensemble des problématiques liées à la
vétusté des parcs immobiliers pour vous
donner une petite est de départ je
demanderai de choisir entre a et b qui à
m'élever choisirait a bien sûr vous êtes
raisonnable ce avait décidé mais dans
les faits malheureusement pour vous vous
avez causé un incident puisque la voie
de délibération était tellement vétuste
qui est une catastrophe donc
nécessairement ce qui est difficile dans
la gestion des infrastructures c'est
d'avoir l'information juste précise à
tout le moins robustes pour pouvoir
prendre la meilleure décision
l'information la donne et doit mener à
la connaissance on a ledge comme vous le
voyez dans la petite blague ici que l'on
voit des enjeux importants
c'est la fiabilité de l'information et
la fiabilité dans le domaine des
infrastructures est liée au fait que
l'on va marquer la donne et ne produit
temporel donc une évolution et ont pu
utiliser la métaphore médicale et une
évolution des tas de santé qui fait en
sorte qu'on doit le monitorer comme on
regarde un électrocardiogramme pour
essayer d'anticiper de façon rationnelle
ou de façon adaptative les situations
qui pourraient mener à la catastrophe
donc je vais essayer de vous parler d'un
système d'information d'une approche de
méthodologie de regard particulier qui
pourrait aider
l'amélioration l'augmentation de
l'efficience économique de la france
comme dans tout les pays tous les pays
industriels faisaient d'ailleurs et les
pays émergents ces approches peuvent
être applicables bien sûr commençons par
regarder un peu ce que c'est de la
vétusté j'ai pris le temps de sortir des
photos un peu moins un spectacle
spectaculaire que celle que vous venez
de voir sur le sujet des universités
donc vous voyez qu'il ya certains lieux
physiques dans des universités en france
donc on n'est pas à l'autre bout de la
planète on est bien en france où
finalement on n'est peut-être pas
assurée sur la trajectoire que nous
suivons le futur n'étant plus ce qu'il
était en égard de vétusté comment
décider comment décider pour gérer ces
situations là de façon pérenne et donc
comment s'inscrire dans une vraie
réflexion d'économie circulaire
d'économies pour laquelle on pourrait
anticiper les besoins de ne pas en
entreprise
d'autre part en matériaux et est
finalement en énergie donc pour avoir
une approche vraiment global et combiné
bien sûr les installations que je vous
montre là sont assez particulières
d'envoi de l'occultation assez
phénoménal la soutenance de thèse s'est
bien déroulée je l'espère
dans ce cas ci on voit des infiltrations
d'eau la chose qui est importante c'est
déjà de comprendre dans quel contexte ce
vieillissement cette vétusté se fait
donc dans quels contextes
organisationnels donc derrière la
vétusté il ya des décisions il ya des
absences de décisions qui ont mené à
cette situation la moye et qu'on est
assez créatifs pour résoudre certains
problèmes de vétusté
et lorsqu'on propose aux gens de se
laver les mains il ya toujours la
solution bien éduqués ou le choix
contraire c'est-à-dire cuir qu'on n'a
pas le choix entre le mmo il lève un
beau but la température ambiante à 13
degrés c'est peut-être parce que plus
rigolo où on est on essaie d'éviter la
qualité d'air intérieur
peut-être que vous inspire dans certains
de vos locaux du décès je souhaite pas
et finalement vous avez compris vous
êtes beaucoup mieux dans l'amphi si
aujourd'hui que dans celui là
donc si on regarde la complexité de tout
ça on pourrait estimer
il n'y a pas de d'estimation officielle
sur le sujet mais si la valeur actuelle
de remplacement si on veut reconstruire
toutes les universités
toutes les écoles tous les hôpitaux
toutes les infrastructures urbaines en
france on pourrait estimer une valeur de
7000 milliards qui représente un peu
plus que deux fois le pib de la france
s'ils ont jeté un chiffre en disant
qu'il faut investir 100 milliards par
année
et donc ce que nous lisons 5 à 500
milliards
on aurait un indice de vétusté physique
et l'expression relative de la vétusté
de cette pour ça à peu près donc
essayons de voir si dans un premier
temps cette estimation est réaliste on
prend un retour d'expérience ici sur un
parc immobilier de 226 bâtiment pour
lequel la moyenne dans une première
étude ou la fiabilité de l'information
était mauvaise
où on avait un indice de vétusté
physique autour de 35% après elle
passait une seconde fois sur les données
on est arrivé à fixer l'ievp autour de
23% donc un facteur plus que 3 par
rapport à l'hypothèse où est la
proposition de départ
ce que veut dire que l'enjeu de toute
façon même s'il est mal quantifiées il
est phénoménal
on remarque aussi que au cours des 20
dernières années dans l'image que vous
avez à l'écran il n'y a pas vraiment eu
de construction neuve
on est resté dans une logique donc
d'exploitation maintenance de l'existant
de réhabilitation de l'existant avec
deux grandes époques l'époque d'après la
première guerre mondiale donc c'est le
premier nuage de points que vous voyez
votre droite et l'époque gauche de
l'après deuxième guerre mondiale et on
voit qui a pas de corrélation entre
large de la vétusté les phénomènes de
dégradation sont liées à trois facteurs
d'une part la conception et la
construction d'origine
d'autre part le niveau d'effort qu'on
aura consenti en maintenance en
entretien en métier d'actifs pour
maintenir la valeur d'usagé au bon
niveau et finalement les sollicitations
de type exogènes le climat la pollution
est de type endogène bien sûr lusage
typologie d'usagé
le jeune de 14 ans pelé testostérone qui
teste c'est vrai que coup de pied on
peut défoncer le plafond où la
religieuse en pantoufles qui sans bruit
se déplace dans le couloir donc vous
avez bien compris que la complexité à
intégrer intégrer toutes ces
informations nous mène une réflexion
comme décideurs des êtres humains qui
vont gérer sans des ingénieurs qui
devront le faire dans les années à venir
comme décideurs une réflexion sur le
cycle de vie sur le financement ou la
possibilité financière de gérer cet
enjeu là sur un horizon pérenne ça vient
aussi bien sûr à mener la réflexion sur
comment est modélisé en terme de
morphologie d'anatomie et de physiologie
les organisations donc comment se
déroulent les interactions au sein des
organes de l'organisation pour essayer
de d'intérêt lié ces informations là de
manière à avoir un alignement ce traité
entre le stratégique et l'opérationnel
donc le plan stratégique dans une
organisation c'est toujours la part du
rêve c'est ce que l'on souhaite ce sont
les intentions politiques ce sont les
contraintes réglementaires aussi et
finalement la réalisation le plan
opérationnel
mais non un constat bien sûr au cours
des dernières années il ya eu plusieurs
plans d'investissement qui ont été
impulsés dans le domaine des hôpitaux
des universités des rénovations urbaines
et bien sûr ces projets n'ont eu un sens
et ont une portée mais il faudrait
capable d'évaluer comment ce set le
reste donc ce qui n'a pas été touchée
évolué pour maîtriser les risques
donc on doit éviter d'être dans la
politique de l'autruche d'une part
landes aussi éviter d'être dans la
politique de l'épouvantail
nous devons être dans une politique ni
3ieme raisonnable de maîtrise des
risques et d'auscultation de la
criticité
il faut donc une boucle récursive entre
le plan opérationnel et le plan
stratégique de manière à pouvoir
proposer aux décideurs un alignement de
la valeur d'usagé et donc une révision
des aspirations
si les réalisations ne suivent pas ou
une amplification des réalisations si on
veut atteindre nos aspirations c'est la
réduction de l'écart entre les
aspirations et les réalisations
on a parlé de l'organisation comme tel
si on regarde le métabolisme et le cycle
de vie d'un bien physique deux ouvrages
d'un bâtiment d'une infrastructure
on verra qu'on a une certaine valeur
d'usagé lorsqu'on construit ce bien et
on essaie de maintenir cette valeur d'
usage à 100% de façon le plus pérenne
possible on observera après un certain
nombre d'années une perte de valeur
d'usagé
malgré des interventions en maintenance
courante tous les jours au quotidien' et
la réflexion sur l'aliénation le fait de
céder de vendre de recycler sera amené
quand il de discussion
sinon nous devrons propose
éventuellement un métier d'actifs
c'est-à-dire un rehaussement de la
valeur d'usagé en gardant les mêmes
usages ou une requalification une
rénovation qui mènera à nouvelle valeur
d'usagé et une nouvelle trajectoire de
cycle de vie
cette trajectoire avec la métaphore de
l'électrocardiogramme amène aussi la
notion de seuil et de cible à partir
desquels on doit déclencher des
décisions bien sûr une perte de valeur
d'usagé de 5% ou de 10% ou de 40% peut
signifier une seule très différents dans
une typologie d'organisation et sur une
typologie d'actifs physique que ce qu'on
soit dans un hôpital ou une université
donc il n'y a pas d'absolu en la matière
mais il ya quand même certaines
observations je vais vous montrer aussi
donc en plus d'avoir l'état de perte de
valeur d'usagé bien sûr il faut regarder
certains autres critères la décision ne
peut pas être unique critère bien sûr il
doit être mon aux critères doit être
multicritères et le critère prépondérant
c'est le risque puisqu'on va regarder en
termes d'éthique conséquentialiste
qu'est ce qui se passe si on
n'intervient pas donc à quoi on adhère à
quoi on renonce bien sûr et finalement
on va coller aux risques pour faire la
formule de criticité dont comment
transcender le simple risque pour
regarder la criticité en regardant
d'autres critères qui sont souvent
qualitatif qui sont souvent d'un autre
ordre et qui viennent en interaction
avec les humains qui sont
dans l'usagé oublions pas que nos
bâtiments nos infrastructures ne sont
que des prothèses de notre vie des
prothèses de l'être humain est une
extension de notre capacité à faire et
donc c'est important de pouvoir le
caractériser les caractériser ses
ouvrages la ses infrastructures ses
actifs physiques de façon multicritères
l'intérêt de cette représentation
multicritères bien sûr c'est la décision
c'est la mise en priorité on pourra
neutraliser les effets malsain d'intérêt
particulier si on peut mieux
caractériser les données mieux
caractériser mieux les agences et
ensemble pour mener à une prise de
décision
sinon nous restons toujours dans le chat
de d'interaction humaine parfois un peu
douteuse en termes de décisions dans ce
cas là on vient aider les décideurs à
voir la réflexion la plus juste ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut impulser une
politique de maintien de la valeur
d'usagé donc une politique qui baignera
dans la notion de maîtrise des risques
et de la criticité
rapidement j'ai créé une entreprise à
l'aide de jeunes diplômés de dut tc
d'ailleurs que je salue au passage qui
me regardent sans doute sur internet
donc je pense la caméra d'abord je les
salue
je les remercie pour leur travail et
donc ils m'aident par la constitution de
progiciels d'applications logicielles
fonctionner ces données et à les
analyser bien sûr l'objectif c'est de
regarder la valeur d'usagé et de trouver
la ligne m'a le plus juste possible
mais autour de ça il ya tout un travail
de valorisation de la valeur de
remplacement de la valorisation de la
perte de valeur d'usagé et bien sûr
l'application de modèle à la fois sur la
mise en priorité et sur l'aspect
prédictif donc de façon à avoir une
vision intertemporelle mais surtout de
façon à amener la réalisation de plats
pluriannuel de travaux qui permettront
de corriger le tir de rehausser la
valeur d'usagé ou simplement d'avoir une
stratégie vente ul d'aliénation en
intérieur et en investissant pas de
façon indue sur le parc donc je vous
montre 4 6 retours d'expériences rapide
vous voyez en bleu la courbe de
dégradations théorique c'est un peu
hermine isme de la durée de vie que l'on
mettrait à chacun des composants sous
l'angle de la physique des matériaux
alors que en rouge vous voyez apparaître
l'action humaine aussi incorporer
puisqu'on a quantifié avec les éléments
qualitatifs dont j'ai parlé
l'effort consenti pour lutter contre la
perte de valeur d usage
on voit que jeunes et en santé c'est
plutôt vrai mais on voit aussi que vieux
et en santé c'est le cas dans ce
bâtiment qui a 40 ans et pour lequel il
ya eu des efforts consentis
l'histoire ne le dit pas dans cet
échantillon de ce qui s'est passé en
amont est ce qu'il ya eu une perte de
valeur d'usagé phénoménale et on a
rehaussé le tout ou au contraire est-ce
qu'un maintien de ben d'autres qualités
de façon constante
mais bien sûr le type d'outils
développés avec tb maestro permet de
capter ce genre d'information et de le
révéler ici on voit une courbe pour un
bâtiment qui a 15 ans et on voit qu'il
ya déjà des phénomènes de perte de
valeur d'usagé qui mérite d'être
observés depuis le prêt pour trouver la
cause d'une part est ce que je te
mauvais couplage conception maintenance
sk une sollicitation et du sk eu un
manque d'efforts consentis en
maintenance au métier d'actifs c'est
important d'essayer de découvrir une
autre courbe de 21 ans et on voit donc à
partir de l'âge de 15 à 21 h 15 à 20 h
pour faire un bandeau large des actifs
physiques comme ceux des infrastructures
urbaines comme ceux des bâtiments
finissent par avoir une accélération de
la vétusté qui pourrait devenir
exponentielle si on laisse aller les
choses dont 33 et finalement mon dernier
exemple un exemple à 40 ans où on voit
qu'il ya une certaine corrélation entre
la courbe théorique est donc une forme
de l'absence de maintenance d'absence
d'efforts qui mènerait une perte de
valeur d'usagé du et donc des
conséquences pour les utilisateurs les
usagers des infrastructures en
conclusion en conclusion si vous me
demandiez quels sont les facteurs de
succès de l'implantation d'une méthode
suivie des infrastructures et de suivi
des données sur les infrastructures pour
vraiment migrer vers une politique de
développement durable une politique
d'économie circulaire d'une part le
premier élément
c'est vraiment de vous inscrire dans la
logique de crédit cit et c'est une
politique de maintien de la valeur
d'usagé qui doit être baigné dans une
culture de la criticité
nous n'avons pas les moyens de
renouveler l'ensemble des
infrastructures systématiquement à un
cycle de 40 50 ans 60 ans vont donc
choisir comment on doit gérer la perte
de valeur d'usagé
le deuxième élément c'est d'avoir une
vision de la décision en intertemporelle
c'est à dire que on ne doit plus
maintenir les horizons annuel
d'interventions sur les actifs mais bien
voir des horizons un minima de 5 à 5 ha
qui est une période pour technique
techniquement bien évaluer la perte de
valeur d usage et financièrement bien
préparé le montage financier afin de
réaliser un projet qui serait ambitieux
et qui verrait transversalement régler
l'ensemble des enjeux et finalement
gardez toujours à l'esprit la volonté de
rétablir l'alignement entre la vision de
la valeur d'usagé observé sur au plan
opérationnel et la valeur d'usagé
souhaiter aux plats stratégique
le philosophe ou où l'humoriste vous
dirais que pour prendre une avance de
succès il faut avoir bien sûr de bonnes
décisions départ pour avoir de bonnes
décisions bien sûr il faut de
l'expérience et pour avoir de
l'expérience faut prendre de mauvaises
décisions donc j'espère que la mauvaise
décision d'une reprise en début de ma
présentation la courte expérience que
vous aurez acquises à m'écouter vous
permettra maintenant de prendre de
bonnes décisions
merci à vous